Nevada needs to recruit more than 5 000
registered nurses just to meet the
national average assemblywoman Sandra
houdegi presenting one of three bills to
the Nevada state legislature this week
the nurse licensure compact she and
members of the Nevada nursing
association and the Nevada Hospital
Association wanting to make Nevada a
nursing compact state which would allow
nurses from out of state to practice
here in Nevada by passing this bill it
will increase access to nursing care for
Nevada patients especially in those
Rural and Frontier counties Dr Lisa
Nicholas the assistant professor for
unlv's School of Nursing also in favor
of this bill as she agrees the help is
needed but wants to make sure that we
are getting quality over quantity trying
to expedite nurses for licensure to work
it's a it's a nice sort of start but you
also have to look at what sort of nurses
they're trying to expedite as for those
opposed to assembly Bill 108 I do not
believe joining the nursing compact
system will ultimately be of much help
many stating to the legislature that
this potential bill doesn't address the
inadequate working conditions nurses in
Nevada have to endure instead of trying
to bring nurses from other states we
should be trying to take care of our own
it is the disservice to our nurses and
patients that we still have not
addressed Acuity based Staffing ratio in
our hospitals currently Nevada is one of
a handful of States not a part of the
nursing licensure compact whereas 37
other states have signed on since it was
created two decades ago
an assemblywoman Sandra houdegi
sponsored the bill and acknowledges that
in no way will it fix the problem in its
entirety but it's meant to fill
vacancies that of which total 2300
vacant nursing positions in our state
Sasha currently the nursing union
represents more than 8 000 nurses and
Health Care Professionals here in Nevada